ah
[Música]
vaya manera tengo 14 años y soy pianista
les quiero platicar de una persona super
especial en mi vida pues las primeras
personas que escuché al salir de la
panza de mi mamá se llama vuelta de la
madre dos masas porque mozart no se me
cae muy bien claro que seremos muy
buenos amigos cuando mis papás cumplido
siete meses de embarazo yo tuve que
nacer de emergencia
por eso me tuve que quedar un mes en
cuidados intensivos en el hospital y ha
visto más mamás los dejaban verme
mediana mañana y me dieron en la tarde
entonces para que no me quedaba solita
me llevaron este dinosaurio de peluche
que cuando le aprietas la patita son la
música
[Música]
y es nada más y nada menos que la sonata
número 16 en do mayor vamos a el primer
movimiento estamos un fragmento de la
pieza
y hay alguien solita en la seguridad en
mi adorable fue que lo conocí
desde entonces quedé fascinada con el
más grande me acompañaba a comer a la
hora del baño y a la hora de dormir me
acerqué a mozart a los tres años cuando
nos regalaron este perrito de juguete
[Música]
pero fue a los cuatro y medio que
realmente lo empecé a conocer
algunas veces con mis primeras clases de
piano y al igual que el aprendizaje de
un instrumento musical era como un juego
un juego muy divertido
descubrí que toda la música
absolutamente toda la importancia es
clásica rock bachata o reggaetón está
dentro de esta gran caja con miles de
cuerdas y miles de componentes que se
llama piernas el chiste es aprender a
dejarla salir al principio esto díaz 15
minutos pero poco a poco se fueron
alargando esos momentos de concentración
hasta que estaba en 45 minutos una hora
y fue ahí cuando el canal 20 que desde
el día 1 no estaba en una lección
la música lo hace todo mejor
si la música lo hace todo mejor me hizo
sentir acompañado todo el tiempo que
estoy en una incubadora me entretenía a
la hora de la comida me relajaba a la
hora del baño le arrollaba a la hora de
dormir la música tiene esa magia de
poner para entrar a tu cuerpo y afectar
hasta la última célula para cambiar tus
sentimientos se les ha puesto la piel
chinita al escuchar una canción bueno
eso es música amén la música para todos
tales para allá en la fotografía son
música con las ciencias música o la
pintura es música o la arquitectura y su
música es ese algo que los apasiona y
los afecta en todo su ser de repente un
día cuando tenía seis años
mis papás mi maestra piano y yo
decidimos entrar a un concurso del piano
algo desconocido para todos nosotros fue
en laredo texas bien en primer lugar en
mi categoría
me sentía soñada y mis papás y mi
maestra nunca habían de felicidad así es
cómo empecé con esta otra parte del
mundo de la música los concursos al año
siguiente entornos nuevamente según
corso en laredo y volví a ganar y así
poco a poco se van acumulando en los
reconocimientos diplomas y trofeos hasta
que un día en un concurso de la ciudad
de méxico iba a tocar una semana que me
costaba mucho trabajo y pues ya estando
ahí frente a todos tocamos con el alma
me equivoqué y gacho me equivoqué tuve
que parar concentrarme y terminar a
tocar la pista como pudiera puedo los
sentimientos más feos que he vivido
sientes las miradas la cara se te
empieza a calentar si no es que el
corazón se te sale con cada latido y por
si es poco tienes que terminar de tocar
con el autoestima en el suelo y claro
con las críticas de los jueces y de
otros participantes
pero esa derrota vergüenza que una vez
más me di cuenta que hemos ajustado otra
adicción no tomarte las cosas tan en
serio
yo creo que por eso a él le gustaban las
bromas las travesuras y pasarla bien
porque sabía que no pasaba nada uno se
equivoca y eso no va a cambiar quién
eres o quitarte lo que más te gusta
hacer mejor aprendamos de los errores y
que siga la fiesta bueno aunque debo de
admitir que a veces mozart si se pasaba
de fiesta llegó el día en que mi maestro
de piano y mis papás se dieron cuenta
que para seguir con educación musical
era necesario algo más profesional
en un festival conoce el director del
conservatorio y a otras dos maestras wow
una experiencia que cambió mi manera de
verdad música intensa musical y el mundo
de los músicos aprendimos muchísimas
cosas
así como hay muchas cosas buenas también
vi el dolor que integra música y eso es
que en todo el mundo a veces los alumnos
son como cabezas de carreras
entrenamiento entrena hasta quebrar de
física intelectual y emocionalmente
acabe frustrada y desilusionada y vamos
a dejar que le quita lo divertido a lo
que amo hacer fue ir cuando mi amigo de
una moda me dio una tercera elección
toma las cosas de quién viene o que
luego como de otros de sus admiradores
también un gran compositor hacerme la
sorda
porque es más la broma
las palabras tienen el poder de herirnos
de quebrarnos de hacernos reflexionar o
incluso de tomar acción y cambiar hay
gente que te puede decir cosas desde la
frustración la envidia o incluso de sus
traumas personales pero hay gente que te
puedo decir cosas desde el cariño la
preocupación y las ganas de verte
triunfar sin que ellos tome el provecho
el chiste es tomar las cosas de quien
viene al ver todo lo que tengan que
hacer para llenar esos huecos tan tan
grandes que me faltaban el gran
conservatorio nacional de música de la
ciudad de mexico
estos años han sido en mucho mucho
trabajo y mucho estudio pero también de
fortalecer mis bases musicales y mis
conocimientos han tenido la suerte de
ser invitado a varios festivales de
tomar clases con grandes pianistas
alrededor del mundo de tocar con varias
de las mejores orquestas del país de
conocer a grandes personas del medio de
tocar en diferentes recintos importantes
hasta de viajar a diferentes países
dos experiencias que nunca se me van a
olvidar es cuando en febrero del año
pasado me presenté en la sala manuel m
ponce del palacio de bellas artes junto
con dos chavos pianistas buenísimos en
un electro que llamaron los jóvenes
promesas del pierna y la otra
experiencia fue viajar a nueva york y
tocar en el carnegie hall en una de las
dos a las chicas en mujeres es tan
bonito que el simple hecho de estar ahí
sin público ya te intimida estas han
sido dos experiencias que nunca nunca
voy a olvidar sobre todo por la lección
que miremos a las cosas cuestan mucha
gente piensa que montar no le costaban
pero claro que le costaban se pasaba
horas y horas estudiando con sus
instrumentos de logias sin ver a su mamá
por meses nada fácil
estoy enseñado que nadie te va a regalar
las cosas en méxico hay mucho talento
gente realmente excepcional de todas las
edades y en todos los ámbitos
pero hay que luchar y abrirse camino
para conseguir las cosas que uno quiere
si se puede hoy en día con la pandemia
se cancelaron muchos planes o se
pusieron en standby en marzo iba a tocar
con una cantante mexicana en italia en
el verano tenía una mini gira en españa
pero bueno no algo que sea gm pero lo
que he hecho es lo mismo que todos
adaptarme hacer las cosas en línea
clases en línea conciertos en línea pero
es curioso porque hábitat que estamos
encerrados he tenido más oportunidades
he dado varios recitales en línea
incluso uno para brasil que lo organizó
un músico de allá y lo último que he
hecho es entrar a un concurso en línea
entre un concurso en viana que se llama
the international music competition
shows bourg durante el país virtuoso es
un concurso que no nos había recomendado
una maestra rusa hace un par de años y
ahora tiene el encierro buscando cosas
que hacer mis papás y yo nos acordamos
grabamos mi vídeo de dos piezas y las
mandamos
pensamos que voy a pasar nada porque es
un concurso durísimo abierto más de 70
países hasta aquí un día mi papá abrió
su mail y allí estaba me llamó para que
viera el mail y en mi iglesia que había
ganado el primer lugar en mi categoría
donde las queríamos obvias y corriendo
ahorita la misma mai que había ganado el
primer lugar es mi categoría de marca
mis maestros y compartir la noticia a
todas las personas que han estado y
están conmigo de pronto me hablaron para
una entrevista luego otra y otra de
radio tele invitaciones para
presentaciones para hacer spot presión y
una fundación ha sido algo increíble
claro que también es mucho trabajo hay
que estar atentos y concentrarse en las
preguntas estar bañada y arreglada desde
tempranito si es algo de tele y claro
ensayar muchísimo porque todos me han
pedido que interprete por lo menos una
pieza y como siempre mis papás de mis
maestros han estado allí al pie del
cañón lo cual me lleva a la quinta
lección que me ha dado mos a valorar el
apoyo que la gente
usar siempre todo el apoyo es papá de su
hermana ya fue el final de su vida que
se dejaron de hablar por cosas de
adultos
mis papás siempre me han apoyado en esto
en la música nunca me ha negado nada que
tenga que ver con esto y creo que si eso
que yo no hubiera podido desarrollar mi
talento pues donde nosotros no conocemos
a alguien que dibujaba increíble o que
corría rapidísimo o que se sabían todas
las fórmulas de patti física en la
escuela qué hubiera pasado si sus papás
nos hubieran apoyado en eso que tienen
potencial o si un maestro lo hubiera
detectado por eso siempre digo una frase
si tienes un sueño no te rindas algunas
conclusiones nada es gratis hay que
trabajar y mucho y si eso trabajar mucho
que sea por algo que realmente te
apasione busca apoyo en todos lados
nunca sabes de dónde van a venir las
oportunidades y mi última conclusión es
que si muchas viviera tendría que verlo
escondidas porque mis papás presse haría
algo horrible si fuéramos amigos porque
aparte de ser talentoso y precoz era un
pelado un grosero y le encantaba hablar
con un doble sentido pero bueno no se
puede todo en la vida
muy afortunada de poder compartir lo que
ha vivido en estos años con ustedes
muchas gracias